he's made a great run as well he just
can't stand his feet
hi i'm jermaine genus and this is rate
my skills with sport bible all right
let's roll
what you got
oh yeah oh my god
benzel
that is a match strike honestly
there is no there's no reason he should
be hitting that ball like that he should
be trying to bend it and he's absolutely
drilled here
top bins bins all
it was stanch this is all kinds of names
that's where it's gone that's why the
keepers nowhere near it
oh nice
these guys
don't you dare
yeah oh my god
i mean
he's not aiming for it but
it's on camera that is incredible
airplane there we go i'd have deleted
that video if i was filming it
sorry i didn't get it
oh
[Laughter]
he probably started doing the front
court from crawl didn't he he's made a
great run as well he just can't stand
his feet
i love this i love this he doesn't know
that
he's probably had a night out the night
before somewhere and he's made a great
run into the channel and can't even stay
on his feet oh that is
see that's a proper free kick he's miles
out there by the way what is he must be
like what 30 yards out there and he's
he's really whipped this one he's got
some technique
best free kick ticker you've played with
well beckham was the best i i'd ever
seen shira during my time at newcastle
he scored one against man united right
and someone's rolled it and he's just
smashed it as hard as he could
and it's like i'm right in the top
corner and i'm saying to him what are
you thinking there when you're trying to
hit this ball he's like i'm just
thinking i'm trying to keep his head off
basically
he's not thinking
i need to bend it in that top corner do
this so he's just like i'm gonna hit
this so hard you are not gonna stop it
oh no there's no there's nothing worse i
don't think in football
it's i'm screaming as well
the poor guy
i don't think you can come back from the
other harassment that is shocking
oh the socks
[Music]
been there
been there i love that i love the face
the face is the the moment he knows
i'm in trouble
trying to catch broken glass
oh stop it ah see i've got time for that
i've got a lot of time for everything to
do that goal
the crossfield ball
he's got his head up zinged one across
lovely ball and the composure some
people rush volleys all the time that's
why they go over they don't let the ball
fall onto their foot and that's what
he's done nicely there it just fell onto
his foot
ain't got to hit too much power the
power's in the cross
[Music]
oh
i think it's nice that i know i mean
when your friends are running off
celebrating
in disbelief about what's just happened
you know you've done something special
in third place i'm gonna go with the
teachers i thought i've been totally
honest
it's just outrageous it's like a once in
a lifetime thing especially the fact
that it was caught on camera in second
place i've got a fella running into the
channel who falls over
it's just too good number one the kid
running down the channel pops it through
the lads legs and smashes it into the
top corner i'm jermaine genus and that
was rate my skills for sport bible
oh oh film level step over oh
me on the floor he's not was it the film
level double lollipop step over
is that what you've thrown in for
yeah yeah we're talking i've been
watching that for 20 years